why
now
have dropped part three because part two
was what 2011 2011 first one 2010 2011
2021 um man just the ups and downs of
the music game you know what i'm saying
loving it being in love with it you know
having some successes you know being
underrated getting to the label stage
taking meetings you know and just
realizing like
like you said my passion is from the
west i would love you know when one of
my staple
you know
i don't know somebody asked me one day
if you had a book about your life what
would you call it and i was like from
the west i would love you know what i'm
saying
and um
so as i'm you know after working with
here boy let's say maybe 2018
2017 2019 last year i put out rap and
roll you know i kind of kept the songs
that i do a hit separate from songs that
i create on my own with other producers
and then we started working and i did a
couple solo songs and i told him like
man you know he was really inspiring me
in like a different way with my music
and i told him like you know what i
think i could make from the west i would
love three you know and i need your help
you know and that was kind of the
beginning of it and that was like a year
and a half ago